Victoria leads the English civ in sid
meier's civilization 6 the british
empire reached its widest expanse during
her 63 year reign she remains one of the
most popular and iconic rulers of
England to this day the English special
ability is called British Museum
archaeological museums have extra
artifacts slots and each museum gives
more archaeologists England gets two
unique units to help secure their
overseas holdings the sea dog is a
unique naval unit that can bully weaker
naval units and capture enemy ships in
addition they get the Redcoat unique
unit redcoats are stronger when fighting
away from the Capitals continent they
can also disembark without using a
movement point for this powerful
overseas force the English have a unique
district in the Royal Navy dockyard it
provides bonus movement for naval units
built their bonus gold for dockyards on
other continents and great Admiral
points the English can be an aggressive
and expansionist civilization but they
can also switch towards a cultural
victory if they set up their museums and
send their archaeologists abroad may the
Sun never set on your empire as you lead
the English to victory in sid meier's
civilization 6
you